why men there's a lot of men I'm gonna
do my best not to touch you okay it's
okay
I'm gonna do my best it's nuts you just
be gentle we are gonna talk about
spoilers though we've all seen the film
Matt and I saw it again tonight
you only seen it once wasn't invited but
that's okay maybe next time honestly
there were only two seats available if
there was if there was a third Hey you
would have been there I've gotta sit on
someone's lap but now you know which one
of you I like more fair enough so uh
low-keyed eyes for now yeah does anyone
really ever die that's the thing
I have no idea like he died in Thor -
that's everyone died but I mean like
there's a scene where where Thor is like
I think it might be this time this film
could have ended up just getting go
right now
Thor I had a really great arc when his
brother died telling him back and we're
just talking about Loki and him killed a
knows we've been doped to end the film
but you just have to continue it and
make more stuff and I'm assuming what my
idea was we'll just being if any war -
whatever the hell's gonna be called I
suppose that the title is supposed to be
like a big spoiler like that's why they
haven't revealed the title yet really
yeah okay brother said anyway well yeah
but as far as what you said you gotta
make a part - you gotta make more money
and essentially that is the plot to this
movie the affinities stone that turns
back time will be what saves everyone in
the next movie but I like the way the
movie opened up I like that Loki died I
like within the first two minutes of
this movie see the Hulk fighting Thanos
I was like okay this is good I like what
I'm watching yeah it's a good opening I
think they're roaster brothers did a
religion I actually liked it a hair more
the second time actually I was able to
just like breathe and have fun and not
be so concerned about like being focused
on everything and also going to press
screenings is cool you know like we all
got to go to a press screening and it
was just like 10 people in the theater
and it was really nice but seeing a
movie with a crowd if they're respectful
it does change the experience like it
does make it a different movie it did
today definitely heightens everything
yeah yeah it definitely would agree with
that
speaking of Hulk yeah great opening
scene but that's the only time you get
to see Hulk in this movie
for about one minute you get hog and
that's kind of a letdown but at the same
time this was such an ensemble cast of
characters the Hulk was almost overkill
and they needed to make the Avengers
will pick underdogs ever so slightly to
Thanos so they're saving the flavor for
Green Hulk in the next movie I really
sty hope they are green Hulk Hulk but I
did like that they gave Bruce Banner
something to do at the end of the movie
where he's in the Hulkbuster suit which
is kind of like cool like the thing that
almost defeated him in the last vendors
movie he's actually in it but it was
underpowered in this movie compared to
in age of Ultron is it was like a shitty
robot mechanism that was falling apart
under its own weight and I noticed a lot
of people in this film not to get nerdy
or weird but every a lot of people were
underpowered in this movie how do you
get all of these like godlike people a
couple of them and one of them actually
is a God into this movie and then have
no one be able to defeat defeat Thanos
so vision he had stabbed in the back
pretty much early on and then his powers
are weakened and like you said the whole
just doesn't want to come out so all of
these people that maybe could
legitimately overpower him are nerfed
essentially which I guess had to happen
and also the movies just like hey
Hawkeye fuck you well you know you have
nothing to do here we don't need you
basically yeah we'll see what little CB
comes back he's gonna be there you saw
that that picture him with like a mohawk
there were really a select moments apart
maybe they savored it the Russo brothers
because like for example Captain
America's really strong dude and so when
Thanos head is and it seems like what
when he's holding it back really liked
Thor's
like new hammer were the hella axe thing
is nor record did like that yeah that
was a really great moment of power like
I said I really wish the film would end
up there to kill them but um yeah so it
was very like weakened for our heroes I
like how they explored Thanos and his
mind like you got to understand his
personality it wasn't just like he was a
big strong punchy guy like there was
pain with Gamora he had a sacrifice
Gamora to get the soul stone it seemed
like it was really hard on him I really
like Thanos in this movie more than I
thought I would they actually made him a
character like you said yeah he believed
human genocide which is it's not the
nicest thing ever but he has a reason
and a logic behind it and it's like oh
you can almost for a second understand
where he's coming from
and finally am i removing purple but I
love josh brolin in this movie and i
loved the way it ends finally in a
Marvel movie the bad guy wins and at the
end of the movie all he wants to do is
commit human genocide sit at his log
cabin looking at the sunset and I'm like
I could almost respect that that's what
you want to do I'm not gonna tell you
which half okay yeah so yeah like right
off the bat hitter Silva he's gone
Loki's gone
okey yeah or is he really into the movie
half of everyone's going
that's a Spider Man Black Panther yeah
Scarlet Witch vision but after we watch
the movie the other day you brought up
an interesting point
the only people remaining or the
original Avengers yes which
coincidentally works out so I kind of
excited to see where the next movie goes
that I feel like I don't know how you
feel by this map but I feel like it'll
be sort of like a great arc from like
the first Avengers the original team and
now it's just them and they have to
figure out how to save the next team so
like a new and maybe a new spider-man
comes in or a new black panther is that
what you mean no I feel like it's gonna
be because like from the first Avengers
and then on to the second the arc seems
to be that it's the old train new okay
and now the new is pretty much all gone
yeah and it's just left with the
originals yeah maybe now the originals
have to make some sort of sacrifice for
the new team that would make a lot of
sense because they have to write them
out eventually so yeah what do they
sacrifice themselves for the betterment
of humanity and indeed hmm well I know
then comics like there's like a new
star-lord she's like a female and like
they switched up some stuff now some of
the newer I didn't see any of it I just
like the covers so there's some new
ideas that they thrown out maybe they're
gonna have New Age Avengers
I'm no I I have no idea I'm excited
that's something I can say that I've
never really experienced before with any
of these MCU movies I really don't have
clue where they're going which is
something I really like is that it's
like half the team is dead thanos one
and he's just sitting on a cabin
somewhere and when it ends it's not like
your typical Marvel credits either it
was almost like a Nolan movie credits
like it was just white text in black
screen and then you get one last and
credits scene but it was so just kind of
dour you're not used to that MCU movie
that's why the Russo brothers were the
perfect choice to direct this that's
what this movie needed and I thought
from a directing standpoint it's the
tone I wanted this movie to because it's
fun but also the action sequences are
gritty and like it gets a little bit
darker and like you said with the inning
scene
it's dour and that's what this universe
needs
I like how samuel jackson fades away
yeah it's like they wrote that it's like
the in the script they didn't put Nick
Fury motherfucker they put samuel
l.jackson motherfucker yeah pretty much
all of my favorite aspects of this film
like beyond the really cool action
scenes that are just fun summer you know
popcorn stuff that's exciting to watch
if you like these characters already
it's exciting I love everything with the
guardians and Thor they did a good job
of like separating different heroes like
we'll put Doctor Strange and Tony Stark
the two snarky guys with goatees in one
place together and just have them
faceoff will put Thor who was introduced
as a more comical presence in Ragnarok
with the guardians and I like I liked
all the stuff that was brought about by
that I know it's some of your favorite
parts in the movie - yeah I could quote
that all day how long would staying
there an hour drags was amazing this no
my god that's amazing everything he is
so good I loved him and the thing is
like I've seen some people who are
concerned that perhaps he's becoming too
much of a joke character I don't care I
need to re-watch guardians too because
that whole scene with mantis that was
beautiful
yeah I think people just need to stop
like looking on internet for their
opinions and just gonna like formulate
their own maybe that's a good idea
maybe while doing here the one thing I
didn't like about the guardians and it
almost felt from a script standpoint it
was out of character
star-lord in this movie is sort of an
insecure asshole yeah and he causes
essentially the destruct
of the universe by not being able to
hold his timber back for five seconds
and they're about to get the Infinity
stones off of Thanos his fist and he
just has to start punching him in the
face that was one of the better scenes
in the film I thought oh that means
really really I want to talk about this
for sure well I want to disagree with
you because as a writer and you have to
put your conflicts for your characters
right so this is a guy who in the
beginning didn't like Gamora and then
now he really likes her and you can see
in his face we were talking about this
earlier like even like crying almost
twice for shooting or shooting two more
than the bolas came out and then the
second time where he's in his face was
my favorite moment in the whole film
like he's actually a human being like he
isn't like just a rock or a robot like
he actually has some emotional
attachment to these people now this is
the third time we've seen him in a movie
so and they even set it up a little bit
like when he's talking to Thor it's a
funny scene but he's like I had to kill
my own father and my mother yeah my
mother's gone and everything and he's
like I think that's I think that's
harder than having to kill a sister like
it's funny but it's true he really has
lost a lot and I feel like maybe Gamora
kind of his last love really that's
alive so I can I can see how a guy like
that would make that mistake it's
frustrating cuz you're like it was right
there can you have waited a couple more
seconds but that's what love is I know I
get it it's frustrating because it makes
star-lord less appealing because you're
like it's your fault but at the same
time out of any character if there was
one that had to do that I would say it
would probably be him because he's the
most human just normal guy out of out of
the majority of them that isn't as
heroic as say Tony Stark is because
Tony's been through more he's had more
life in death scenario so you already
tried to give his life for New York in
the first Avengers and star-lords had to
do a lot of terrible decisions too but I
feel like maybe that was just sort of
like the last straw
like his mom okay that was terrible my
dad okay that was terrible oh now Gamora
cam done so I kind of feel with you I
kind of agree with both of you really
it's it was a little out of character
but if anyone had to make that choice I
would say it was him I feel like it's
more appealing at least to me because if
he makes it more human then it's it's
more human but they also had a
plan in place to save the universe and
at the last second we make mistakes we
do and I agree with that but not even
from that scene the whole movie he was
sort of an unlikable character and I I
feel like that was just the one out of
place character in the entire movie that
didn't really mesh with previous other
films if you make a person in the film
like a character rather than a human
being which one are you gonna you know
say oh yeah I'm more connected to the
human being rather than the character in
the film so I feel like star-lord in
this movie was more of a human being or
anything like a character written in a
script to me what those all the
decision-making he's with you I feel
like if any character should have caused
that incident maybe like the plan to
fail should have been Drax because he's
the one who lost his entire planet the
Thanos and he lost his temper in the
first that's a good Guardians movie
where he made the plan fail the first
time so maybe I feel like maybe that
character would have worked better for
that situation
maybe they kind of had him almost lose
his shit the first time he sees Thanos
and then I feel like after he got sliced
up in the Domino pieces he probably was
like I'm not doing that again
it's being of that big action sequence
as I say that wouldn't put my hands on
both your shoulders how's this feel do
you feel like a team a unit
yeah I've no really team one all right
anyway um thank you for that Chris
so yeah this being that action sequence
like you were saying like it was so
suspenseful and you know it's been a
while since a movie really got me in the
edge of my seat and even though these
movies for the most part sometimes are
predictable that was one scene where I
was like oh my god are they gonna be
able to get the affinity stones and it
was just so well choreographed and
executed it was it was one of many
sequences in this movie that really
truly impressed me and I went into this
movie knowing that I was gonna get these
huge blockbuster sequences but they
still impressed me and I was that was my
favorite things about this movie yeah
it's for the better action scenes really
all the actions good the Russo brothers
are very good with with action and
making it feel tangible where soldiers
good film in the sense it was a good
story
same with civil war but someone I notice
with them and something I don't like in
films is like the direction of action
when you're just like close up and I
can't see anything that's going on with
having a Winter Soldier like the first
on the boat whatever like the deck
they're fighting I can't see a damn
thing was
because everything was just all
close-ups and quick cuts but in civil
war they improved and everything was a
little wider a little bit more breathing
for the editing this film was actually
like awesome actually see what the
hell's going on so I think maybe I don't
know if they're improving as filmmakers
but this one's the one with their like
it really did a good job of letting me
see everything yeah cuz I'm not too good
job I'm more of a John wick fan I like
to see everything as much as possible in
the frame and as long takes as possible
and this film actually gave that to me
yeah this was grandeur it felt bigger
and I know we didn't get to see it in
IMAX tonight but the entire film was
shot with IMAX camera really Wow what
the entire thing that's incredible again
okay yeah that's the first so I kind of
want to go out of my way to see it in
IMAX 3d IMAX theaters pretty far it's
Columbus or Detroit
yeah so all the stuff on Wakanda was you
know a big army fighting the Avengers
and every Avengers movie has a big like
bug army or robot army or alien bug army
bug people I like the one that I like I
like seeing people just get punched in
the face you know like everyone like dog
thing almost looks like venom look
they'll make the creatures from a quiet
place a little bit and maybe John
Krasinski's in the background like Shh
one of my favorite shots in the movie
from an action standpoint was all of
them were Condon's advancing and then
you just see Black Panther and Captain
America mm-hmm like running faster than
everyone else really that's what I need
I need like that intensity I need that
excitement and that was pretty awesome
yeah that whole scene every one of these
big movies where you have different
locations and all the action sequences
are happening back-to-back you need the
hand-to-hand combat scene that's what
the Wakanda scene was that scene also
reminded me of an episode of Game of
Thrones where they have the same almost
sequence and instead of the Hulkbuster
in the game of thrones they have a big
giant speaking of Game of Thrones
there's a man in this film named Peter
Dinklage alone yeah he's great tonight
because we got to see with the crowd
this is another reason the crowd helped
it was seriously
he went like he was like he turns his
face like three guys went yeah he was
good it was it was entertaining there's
yes there's some good lines like Thor is
like he's trying to open up the the star
machine and he's like it's going to kill
you and he's like only if I die yes
that's that's what killing you means
there's a lot of great lines in there
too I love again with Thor hyoni beams
down to the battlefield he sees Chris
Evans and Chris Evans like new haircut I
see you've copied my beer rabbit yes
it's all sprinkled in there perfectly
like it's not overwhelmingly cheesy or
corn and it's just perfect they get a
one-liner in there and then they go into
battle that sounds like a made-up work
always it made up it's really good I
love some of the funniest lines in this
movie area actually off screen one of
the guardians and Ironman inspire men
are kind of like having some banter on
Titan and mantis is like is it Kevin
Bacon like world's greatest hero and he
and spider-man's like from Footloose and
Star Wars says this is still the
greatest movie and off screen here
spider-man it never was it's like a
great little movie nerd moment yeah
speaking of my old pop culture
references there's probably something in
here that you love they use it as a plot
device where the reference aliens old
movie it's not that old it makes it
funny
he's so young he thinks it's 86 just
like Empire Strikes Back in Civil War
you're like the old movie Empire Strikes
Back so I guess they're just gonna keep
doing have nobody else our brother
spider-man movies but um and then
Squidward gets launched out of the the
whole when you call him Squidward yeah
that was perfect yes good good humor in
this movie yeah I mean it's dark you
know it's hi I'm Peter oh my music fake
name what I like about this movie even
though it does feel so hopeless like as
the heroes don't seem to have like a
single glint of that victory in sight
it's still kind of funny
no it's not just like it's like huh like
you don't leave like oh my god I it was
it's a fun experience it feels like they
were doing their best include every
character in this movie give giving them
they're seeing something to do to please
people but at times it just feels like a
scene and then a scene and then a scene
and there's no rhythm
there's disk enjoin 'td almost a little
bit it can be hard to I can't really
imagine like the daunting task of
creating this movie with all these
characters because yeah
watching in a second time I was able to
see more clearly like every major
character gets like a big introduction
scene that usually involves an action
scene or a fight of some kind Scarlet
Witch envisioned oh they're in Scotland
and here comes a big fight they do that
with pretty much every character and
they find a pretty cohesive way to blend
it all together but yeah it does kind of
feel like a bunch of awesome huge
moments and it doesn't always flow it's
a little uneven a little clunky but I
think on second viewing for me it did
flow a little better and like I said it
could have something to do with just
being able to sit back and relax and not
be so concerned about watching
everything and making sure I see
everything that happens and it was just
sort of like that's just have fun and I
think if it was a little bit better the
second time for me
did you notice throughout Thanos has the
opportunity to kill a lot of people but
he simply chooses not to do it there was
a time where he killed in the first five
minutes of movie he could have killed
Thor Thor's wrapped in metal Thanos
could have just killed him right there
in the spot does it takes off there's a
few other scenes where Thanos has the
ability to kill different Avengers and
he simply doesn't do it and he just
leaves the senior I think it's because
he doesn't want to just murder people
because of murder I think he just wants
to exterminate half of yeah like in his
head he's the hero of his own story sure
like he thinks I'm doing something right
I'm a good guy yeah he'll make this
necessary sacrifices yeah like even with
star-lord
when star-lord does yes shoot more even
though he doesn't yeah he's like I like
you and then he backs away into his
little formal or whatever yeah he feeds
into his own ideology and here's the
moral code you mean if he is a villain
or a bad guy
yeah he has to have this standard and
you can't deviate from that I thought
talking
earlier these moments of Chris Pratt
star-lord
with the gun twice for Thanos and I
really liked it I thought Chris Pratt's
acting was fantastic and crying and
actually I talked about this we went to
the car to come back here after he saw
for the second time I felt in that
moment the first time when he's got the
bubbles in the gun when he has to kill
Gamora I felt myself like projecting
into his like role like what if I had to
kill the person I love it's just like
holy shit like this is some heavy stuff
that I'm starting to really feel from a
Marvel movie it really felt great yeah
they gave star-lord some of the hardest
choices in this movie he you know
commits to killing the woman he loves
and then he's put face to face with a
guy who actually does it yeah he is a
great range of where he can do the
comedy like oh I'll get a bowflex but
then like I can just feel for his
character in those moments which is in a
Marvel really really outstanding jobs
yeah despite how these movies are
generally viewed as fun popcorn movies
and not much else they do a great job of
understanding what are the hardest
decisions that certain characters have
to make and then forcing them to make it
I'm in Civil War they make Thor watch
his brother die now that's his brother
his mother his sister and his father and
there's a great scene between him and
rocket where Rockets like okay I guess I
gotta be the captain and he goes and
walks over and talks to him it has a
little heart-to-heart moment and and
Thor is crying but he's he's trying to
like act like he's you know big macho
man and everything and he's like oh you
know what else could I lose that was
really great acting too because he's
trying to smile and stuff but the whole
time his eyes were watering that's great
acting yeah so it's a fantastic film
these actors honestly like you can say
what you want about the MCU and
everything but they've done an amazing
job casting these movies makes perfect
casting it really is I mean you can't
see anybody else playing these
characters really really no mistakes in
regards to casting everyone is just
really on point and I think this movie
is a blast like honestly it's it's just
it has a few issues really I am excited
to see it a third time I want to see it
again yeah just talking about it makes
me excited to go see it again I knew
when we were watching in the theater the
first
I was there scenes that you have to
watch a second time to really get it all
in it gave me what I expected but a
little more like I honestly did not
expect it to just end with half of T
Avengers and the superheroes fading into
dust I'm sure some of them will be back
there's no way they're just going to be
like well there's no Black Panther - it
was immensely successful and everybody
really liked it but we're not going to
make another one I'm sure they'll come
back in some way shape or form but I'm
curious to see how and I really don't
know how which is something I'm excited
to see I think as you've said and we've
said 100 times before superhero movies
only as good as its villain and if
anything from the first Avengers film
where you get that crappy CG shot of
Thanos turning his head - now you've got
a real character in this movie and I
bought into it and everything that was
happening and and the consequences and I
loved it I loved famous in this film
that was the biggest surprise and I
didn't think much going into this movie
I was pleasantly surprised by it so -
thumbs up I agree with both of you I
have a really badass phone I really
liked hello yeah I like to say I don't
know why people really harp in hella
chill out of power sing with Thanos why
do people like tail so much use bad
asking a lot of power so like when you
take Thor's hammer and break into your
first scene that's pretty bad she knows
first like big action sequence she's
whipping everybody's ass in Asgard
that's really awesome so that's very
underrated so Marvel is doing a great
job with the villains and I don't know
how I felt about the ending and when we
saw its press screening and I really
appreciate it for being ballsy as hell
yeah and also we're gonna see the
continuation next year so I feel like
this movie will perhaps improve a little
bit once we see the full arc absolutely
if the second one's better or at least
as good as this
so yeah Avengers infinity war we all
liked it a couple little nitpicky issues
but it's a good movie if you've been a
fan of the MCU for the past 10 years or
even before that you love the comics
you'll probably enjoy this thanks so
much for watching definitely subscribe
to my friend flick pink you can see his
link in the description below my friend
matt as well his channels in the
description thank you so much as always
for watching guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes I'm gonna go watch the Thor
Ragnarok because you made me want to
yeah you're gonna want to now - second
greatest Winter Soldier said second no
second graders we're watching
second-greatest MCU film let's go
[Music]